is over it is time to talk about Warzone
2.0 we got a glimpse of some Warzone 2.0
in the multiplayer multiplayer reveal
trailer earlier today and it does look
awesome however we need some true
experts to help out back at the desk
here we have got Stephanie Snowden Josie
got to join us but of course welcome
Jack O'Hara game director at Infinity
Ward Joe how we feeling we're running a
party here I mean this is uh this is a
lot we need to know everything Warzone
2.0 Stephanie the world cannot wait it
it feels crazy for me to be up here
revealing war zone 2.0 I ended up at IW
as a fan of the game and so this moment
is absolutely bananas for me but Warzone
2.0 is everything that we loved about
the original war zone right where it
it's based on the same experience that
we all had that that fund all of those
moments and it's a it's a return to
Shared Tech Across the Universe for
Modern Warfare 2 and that's going to
create a really streamlined player
experience and um I think the key
innovations that we discussed for
multiplayer those all exist across
warzone 2.0 as well so we're bringing it
back it's all connected it's the same
world and I think the players are going
to love it oh my good God real excited
about this one I got again there's a lot
in this one Jack uh where do we go from
here so MW2 and wasn't to have been
developed side by side since the
beginning right since we started down
this road and they're part of the same
universe like Stephanie said they share
the same mechanics the same weaponry and
even more than that but the centerpiece
of all this of course is the new map
that we've been working on since 2020
with teams across the globe it brings
together our philosophies on map design
it brings together new technologies in
order to do it and lots and lots of
artwork to make it happen and we've
learned so much from players
experiencing verdansk and playing into a
dance over the the first few years of
Warzone and we're really excited then
for them to land in al-mazra with their
squad there's a wide variety of points
of interest for players to explore in
this map and we're really looking
forward to seeing everybody in there oh
here we go a brand new map to explore
and reverse I cannot wait it's
definitely let's take a look that's
right miles welcome to El mazura this is
our new map for Warzone 2.0 it is a
really interesting mix of geography it
is expansive desert settings with a mix
of industrial areas towns a city and of
course water it looks way better on this
screen than it did on Twitter
but you're gonna find a lot of really
cool elevation Rocky Peaks caves
Subterranean spaces this map is
beautiful and it's actually the biggest
VR map that we've ever made and I am so
excited for all of our streamers here to
jump into almazwell later today it's
huge look at the size of that thing uh
okay so that was a big picture and it's
a great way to see it from a sort of
top-down layout but uh let's take a
better look at some of these points of
interest
so when we set out to create these
spaces the team Works to make it feel
like a real space right so that there's
infrastructure in between all the
different what we call points of
interest along the map and if you're
paying attention you might even see a
few that seem pretty familiar out there
as well
um and so as the team Works through
these they're trying to find some
variety on each point of interest to
make them then something that the
players will want to drop in and get the
particularity of that single point of
interest and find the place that they
want to drop and where they want to play
whether it be a high elevation
Observatory at the center of the map
whether it be the big city that's up the
top right and whether they want to
explore that or whether they want to
work in some of our pois where we have
water intersecting with with geometry
here so we have in this one that looks
familiar
and there's a river system that goes
through all of this so you'll be able to
catch in a boat and drive between the
different pois and here's one of our
favorites sour Village which is that's
my favorite collectively called sunken
town I mean I love to swim so you find
me there absolutely um I'm curious what
you guys think Jack and Joe on what the
hot Drop will be today right we've been
talking about this last couple days this
is our first time seeing other people
who are not us play Warzone 2.0 and so
I'm just very curious where you think
everyone's gonna immediately drop today
I I think some people are going to drop
to Observatory just to go go back to
home you know they're coming home it's
always nice you're moving through the
map and you kind of hit a spot and
you're like wait uh I've been here
about these flashbacks oh yeah there's a
lot of nuggets in there for some old uh
yeah I'll say Corey I think that's gonna
pop off I think people will land around
the edge so they stay in as long as
possible in this match but we have some
news
for our edge of the map players coming
up all right guys well the map looks
absolutely gorgeous and I can't wait to
watch our streams here uh drop in early
in an alpha build later on today okay so
moving on to the gameplay uh we've got
this beautiful space to play in how do
all of these multiplayer elements we've
talked about a little bit earlier how do
they fit into Warzone 2.0
I mean the super simple answer is all
the stuff we talked about and
multiplayer the stuff you saw in the
multiplayer trailer that's all in
Warzone right it's all integrated so
that tactical camera Works in Warzone
that Decoy mine works in version like
it's all that's been built from the
ground up for both
the slide that dive the water like
more swimming yeah
this is a great taste of some of the
Water Combat I can't wait to go full
Captain Miller you know Apocalypse Now
coming out of the water knife in people
I mean this just looks yeah the
rendering team made some work so you
come out you're looking all wet yeah see
the car sticks on the bottom I'm not
even sure what caustics are
I have no idea but it sounds great and
it looks incredible you can see the
armored Patrol boat coming by there with
its two turrets it's there's some cool
stuff so I'm glad you brought up
vehicles uh so have you touched on
vehicles a little bit earlier what can
we talk about uh you know we see boats
we've seen tanks we've seen all sorts of
track what we got so we've implemented a
new physics and handling model for the
vehicles so some vehicles are heavier
some will slide more have more traction
or less traction and as you're driving
them around and you're encountering them
and other squads are playing with them
you can choose to shoot off the tires to
kind of impact their handling you can
have them they react to explosives
differently based on their weight so if
you're in a heavy armored 4x4 and get
hit by an RPG it's going to kind of
Bounce a little bit but not quite take
the hit as a small sedan you can also
choose with your squad to be rolling
into a POI and somebody jumps out on the
roof somebody leans out the window and
suddenly get yourself a lot of Firepower
driving into the POI of course that
vehicle needs to survive for quite some
time in the map if you want to keep
using it to go from point to point and
vehicles will run out of gas or at least
most of them will will run out of gas
and then you can bring them to a gas
station to fill them up if your tire has
been blown up you can get out and repair
it or you can bring it to a gas station
to get repaired as well and of course
we've got you know water Vehicles we've
got a small boat we've got the boat that
Joe mentioned with the turret turret at
the back so you can have that little
moment cruising up the river with your
whole Squad ready to rumble so yeah
there is so much love that's gone into
these videos
the coolest vehicle massive helicopter
that you can fly around that's a big
platform with three doors and people
play you can move a whole Squad through
the map what wreak havoc it is so cool
oh my God I mean the fact that you can
lean out of the window you know grab
your teammates Pile in a vehicle
actually you know engage in battle from
the window leaning out unless somebody
blew off your door
that does complicate things so you get
PTSD from uh Joe killing me many times
in our play tests well I hope the gas
prices in our mother okay I thought
there's a lot going on in Warzone 2.0
and uh my head is quite frankly spinning
uh what are the mass I know there are
guns but do we shoot them what's
happening but what do you want to jump
into first oh except we've made some
pretty sweeping changes I think to the
high level components of of War Zone 2.0
to continue providing players with both
a dynamic and rewarding VR experience
but Warzone 2.0 you're going to hear it
over and over again today it's about fun
this is about playing with your friends
having fun you know Friends new and old
maybe you're making them a game and I
think one particular feature that I
cannot wait to see the streamers engage
with will be our prox chat yes so it's
coming it will be in war zone and I I
there is going to be some amazing clips
but um
I think Joe can uh tell us a little bit
more about looting and about 2.0 I'm
listening
um you know in looting in Warzone 2.0 we
still have the humming crates you know
you can still travel around and listen
for those who still have the loose Loot
on the ground but we wanted to add a
layer of learnability and and logic to
our looting right so if you if you're
outside if you're a little kid you fall
down you hurt your knee and your mom's
gonna go inside go to the medicine
cabinet and get you something to a
Band-Aid Neosporin whatever so that's
our looting if you're you need health
items you can hit a bathroom in a
building and there'll be a medicine
cabinet you can open it up
um if you want to get Loadout items
there are these hidden caches throughout
in between the pois that are in ground
and you can memorize where they are
because they're always there so you can
kind of start to develop these paths
through the map of how you Loot and
there's this logic applied to looting
you know you can find toolboxes that'll
have grenades and things in them
um and you find these other crates that
are kind of like it's as if the the
military that occupied this space came
through and dropped off military items
those crates are always there so you can
always have this reliable layer to
looting incredible this sounds really
exciting we go on a road trip through
our mother and quite literally like have
a route we plan hit the gas station yeah
yeah pick up snacks pick up ammo and all
sorts Okay cool so what about Circle
mechanics I mean this is obviously a
huge component of br's check yeah I mean
the circle's been a staple of br's it's
been really hard to move away from it so
we kind of talked about what could we do
to mix things up with the circle so
we've got this new mechanic where the
circle can actually split almost like a
cell split into two three or even four
circles and then those circles kind of
close down and what it does is it
segregates teams and you have these
micro battles in those circles and a
certain point you're like okay we've
cleared out our Circle we think we're
good and then those circles merge they
come back together and you know you have
this very directed Fight of like as the
circle's moving you're like gearing up
in buildings you're like here we go it's
about to kick off and as soon as those
circles hit you have that final fight so
it's another kind of like twist in the
gameplay that we feel like is a cool
world event that would happen like the
circle splitting we need to do X crazy
get in the car we're going now go all
right so apart from apartment circles
playing uh what about the gulag is that
still around I mean it's so much change
man I mean I'm ready for it but Joe what
do we got the gulag you know we've been
experimenting with we've tried some
crazy things
the the current version of the gulag
that we we have running right now we're
exciting people to play is you're not in
there alone you actually have this
temporary alliance with another opponent
in the map and you guys you have to work
together and if you can defeat the other
team you can get out and after that you
guys are enemies again but for that
moment it's like all right we need each
other let's do this you use the
proximity chat to talk to each other and
the other thing we've been playing
around with is you may see a little bit
of an AI presence in the gulag so you
kind of you have to be on your toes like
you're working with an enemy there might
be an AI here you're picking up weapons
um we're excited for people to try it
yeah we're gonna get feedback today too
and and like Joe said we've been through
some pretty wild iterations of the gulag
which I will not reveal here but uh
there's there's a lot in store
if there certainly is a lot in store um
Jack I have heard of A New Concept
coming to Warzone 2.0 called strongholds
that will include AI that may impact how
players get their weapons Etc uh can you
clue me into what that's all about and
if it's even true absolutely um so
strongholds are reinforced buildings
that they are that the AI is occupying
inside Al mazara in BR and the players
can choose whether or not they want to
engage with them and assault them to get
core rewards including free Loadout
items which is one of the new ways that
we're adding for players to get their
hands on their best weapon we've worked
really hard to bring AI into at scale
into war zone two and you're going to
encounter them in multiple modes in
different way in BR specifically they're
in these strongholds and if you get to a
stronghold you can find the location of
a black side which is going to have even
cooler stuff in it and you can fight
your way from one to the next but in
other modes you're going to find the AI
occupying large portions of the map and
just kind of protecting different pois
in different ways unreal Okay so we've
all heard the rumors that Warzone 2.0 is
going to have some very very interesting
new modes uh would you care to confirm
or deny Stephanie Snowden it's finally
time at launch I am happy to announce
DMZ Call of Duty's extraction mode will
arrive with Warzone 2.0 AT launch later
this year I play DMZ for the very first
time on my first day at IW and to this
day playing it non-stop the
possibilities with this game mode blow
my mind so DMZ I can also confirm the
DMZ is real so we're not gonna go into
depth on it today because we do have to
keep some stuff in reserve what I can
tell you though is we've created a rich
sandbox where you can Define your own
win condition you infiltrate al-mazra
you accomplish your goals and then you
decide to extract when the time is right
it is played across the whole map and
the AI is occupying large sections of
the map and they are lethal opponents
and they do command your respect you
have to watch out for them you have to
work with your team they Patrol areas
they occupy strongholds and they'll
reinforce based on players actions
and then on top of all this you can
choose which Mission you want to
accomplish or you can chase after a
variety of activities in the world and
you can play this differently depending
on your play style you can go loud like
I always do you can go quiet or you can
hunt other players or avoid them
entirely or you could just decide hey
I'm going to explore the secrets of Al
mazara and see what's there loot up
x-fill it's it's totally up to player
choice there and um I'm really excited
about the full scale of what we're
delivering for this chapter and we want
players to have an amazing experience in
war zone 2.0 we've been listening to the
conversations in the community
specifically around small Maps Ricochet
anti-cheat ranked play and Beyond and
trust me although we're touching on some
of the core updates to the overall
Warzone 2.0 experience today and mostly
focusing on BR there will be more news
to share over the coming months this is
only the beginning for Warzone 2.0 okay
I need Warzone 2.0 and DMZ in my life
ASAP Stephanie Wynn Warzone 2.0 will be
free to play for everyone on November
16th with the start of season one across
Modern Warfare 2 mark your calendars
that's about two weeks uh after
after Modern Warfare 2 launches
um and we had a 125 million players in
the original war zone and I cannot wait
to see all of you and hopefully more of
you in almazara for this experience
and you will have a chance to see a war
zone 2 Battle Royale Alpha play test
happening right here behind us very very
soon yeah the stream is a hot to trot
they're raring to go uh we will see all
of you in Alamosa November 16th but
don't go anywhere just yet stick around
because when we come